Speaker 1: Let's start today talking a little
bit about vaccines at this relatively later
stage in the pandemic for the United States,
there's much still to be done globally.
But at this stage in the US, where we could
be moving even more quickly in crushing the
virus, 41 percent of Republicans still refuse
to get themselves vaccinated.
And sadly, this number is down only two percentage
points from last month.
You might remember last month we had a new
poll which said.
Forty three percent of Republicans are refusing
the Kohat vaccine.
That has declined, but only two percentage
points to one.
This is a new PBS NPR Marist poll which finds
that only four percent of Democrats say I
don't want the vaccine.
And yet 41 percent of Republicans say they
do not plan to get vaccinated.
And this truly could lead to more eventual
deaths for Republicans than for Democrats,
which would at least to some degree, shift
the electoral balance.
What I mean by that is if mostly Republicans
are dying, once we get to the point at which
everyone who wants a vaccine has gotten a
vaccine, it seems that would be bad for Republicans
in their races.
And maybe that and that alone at some point
or in some way will influence Republican elected
officials to encourage their voters to get
vaccinated.
But consider the absurdity of this situation.
The people who all along have been saying
there's really no serious pandemic here.
We don't have to do anything special.
We don't have to go out of our way to behave
any differently, open everything right away,
get masks off those very people who are the
ones that never wanted to wear masks and don't
want to get vaccinated are the ones that say
open everything well, wearing the mask and
get when that was the right thing.
Before we knew that vaccinated people no longer
need to wear masks per the CDC getting vaccinated,
that would help us open as quickly as possible.
And yet they are refusing to do it.
Now, overall, 24 percent of the entire country
does not plan to get vaccinated, which is
OK for herd immunity once kids can get vaccinated.
What I mean is if we do vaccinate 76 percent
of all Americans by all measures, that's enough
to completely crush the curve and get to a
practical herd immunity.
There will be sort of like a super immunity
in states where people almost all want to
get vaccinated.
Places like California, New York, Massachusetts,
where there's more than 90 percent interest
in vaccination, they will have like a super
immunity.
On the other hand, you will have cluster outbursts
among unvaccinated people in some parts of
the country that are not so big on getting
themselves vaccinated.
But the issue is no longer vaccine supply.
And that's maybe one of the most infuriating
aspects of this.
We have the incredibly fortunate situation
that many countries are dreaming of, which
is vaccines for everyone.
There are countries desperate to get vaccines
and start vaccinating people.
We have vaccines.
All adults are eligible.
Anyone 12 and over is eligible for the Fizer
vaccine in most states.
You can now just walk in no appointment, just
go and get a vaccine.
And 41 percent of Republicans just don't want
it.
And it's a very similar situation with abortion.
I've used this analogy before.
They say we want zero abortions.
Great.
We know how to get in that direction, give
everybody contraception at no cost out of
pocket, teach everybody comprehensive sex
education.
This reduces the number of unwanted pregnancies
and it reduces the demand for abortions.
Oh, no, we don't want to do that.
That's crazy.
That either violates our conscience or it
violates our religion or violates our morality
or whatever the case.
That's how you reduce abortions, though, and
they don't want to do it.
And it's the exact same thing here.
Hey, we want everything back to normal.
Cool.
Just wear a mask for now until the CDC says
you don't have to.
And as soon as you can get yourself vaccinated,
get yourself vaccinated.
Oh, no, not that that we're not going to do.
It is fascinating that many of the same people
who believed in hydroxy chloroquine, absent
any reason to believe in it as a treatment
for covid don't believe actual science like
vaccines.
The good news is it's mostly the unvaccinated
who remain at risk.
Now, it's not 100 percent like that because
there are some people who can't get vaccinated
because of specific medical conditions.
So you getting vaccinated protects them.
There are people remember when we say the
vaccine is ninety two to ninety five percent
effective, that means five to eight percent
of people who get the vaccine up.
But because of a normal bell curve, distribution
never develop antibodies.
Even though they did go and get themselves
vaccinated.
So do the respectful.
Do it for your fellow Homo sapiens, go and
get yourself vaccinated, not necessarily or
not only because you're assessing your personal
risk, but because you're a member of society,
you're a member of the human race, and maybe
you would do something that has somebody else
in mind.
I know that that's a crazy idea.
So the bad news.
Forty one percent of Republicans still don't
want the vaccine.
The good news, if we are to focus on the good
news, is mostly the risk of people not vaccinating
is to themselves, although there is still
risk to others.
And that number has gone down a little bit,
43 percent to 41 percent.
It's a little bit better.
We'll continue to track vaccination numbers
and maybe have an update, maybe tomorrow,
maybe
on Thursday.